okay are we live now
all right thank you very much well good
evening fellow councillors
welcome to those the public who are
following us on youtube as well
so um we start with item number
one which is apologies for absent okay
sorry chad do you want to start with a
ro should we start with a roll call
sorry
yes actually online yeah we'll do
so is sandra going to do that yes chair
already can
cancel about him yes i'm here pencil
brenton councillor bright
yeah councillor brown
yeah councillor bushby yeah
councillor craigie yeah chancellor
christie
councillor clark here councillor cottle
hunkin
yeah dancer dart
dance counselor forward
[Music]
yeah counselor gab
yeah hawkins
yep it's in a hippo yeah
it's a hex
he is online sandra he's up here
thank you councillor hodgson
present pencil hurley
here councillor hutchins yeah
prince wrench here
pencil james
again james come on wake up
sorry i'm here i was reading sorry
thank you councillor jones
councillor laws yeah
here cancel leather
here counselor lock yeah
present pencil mckenzie
present chancellor manley
brydon councillor newton
yeah chancellor pennington
chancellor rossi here
watson yes
thank you chair thank you very much well
it's a very good attendance actually
there's only a couple missing really so
uh
we now go to item number
two public contributions and i believe
we have a
a uh member of the public wish to speak
okay i think you'll have to take
apologies for absolutely oh
i wasn't all right so sorry i'm sorry
about the apologies
is there apologies yes yeah i have one
apology
wiseman oh all right thank you for that
okay so now uh item two then the public
contribution
thank you
check can i just let you know that
councillor jones has joined the meeting
all right thank you so this is kathy
slaughter has to speak on a general item
7b
is that right
all right this is um kathy ready
okay just check and see if kathy's still
online
all right
um public speakers not not online not in
the waiting room
right well there's nothing to do with in
that case we'll we'll move on then to
item three declarations of interest well
you know the procedure on that ladies
and gentlemen
so uh there you're interested when the
item comes up
four is it uh agreement gender items
part one and two
now really we we have to take a vote on
this
and i think when we look at our
constitution we need to perhaps look at
this
particular item again because we then
have
later on when we move into part two we
have to take another vote so it sounds a
bit cumbersome to me
however i think that's the rules on our
constitution at the moment so
sandra we have to go through the voting
procedure
thank you chair pennsylvan
or councillor brenton or
councillor bright or
pencil lebron four councillor bushby
or penciller craigie or
councillor christie
before
or cancel a cab
counselor cub
four pencil a hacker
four penciller harding or
chancellor haines or penciller hawkins
or councillor heppo
four penciller hicks poor
jones four
sorry counselor james or
counselor laws or penciller langford
for councillor leather or
penciller
or counselor newton
or chancellor pennington or
councillor rossi
and councillor watson oh
thank you that's one against chair okay
thank you
sandra so um
okay if i may we've got somebody back in
the
waiting room um it may be the the public
speaker
all right i don't know if you want to go
back
yeah tom just admits now
all right
okay yes there is the the public speaker
so if you
uh wish to talk to that right yes
we'll go back to item two technology
being what it is i think uh we must make
allowances
all right so um
thank you very much good evening um
councillors can can you hear me
yeah you can okay okay um
today couldn't be a more appropriate one
to be debating councillor haim's motion
to promote safe cycling and torridge
because today the government has
announced a scheme to combat obesity
by amongst other measures promoting
cycling
65 of adults in england are obese or
overweight
this is a health time bomb leading aside
this increased risk of serious
complications
from kovid 19 amongst the overweight
i represent a recently formed group the
northern devon cycling campaign
whose aim is to support and promote a
north devon wide network of safe cycle
routes
by uniting community groups local
councillors
health professionals and individuals
with expertise
we heartily welcome the trench of
initiatives and hopefully of funding
to support healthier lifestyles coming
from central government and will give
our full support
to torridge district council in its
efforts to create a coherent
and cycling cycling and walking
infrastructure
and several campaign members are indeed
watching this meeting
on tdc's youtube channel as i speak to
you
we have also provided you with a map of
ideas for creating a more joined up
system of cycle routes
in and around biddeford which will form
part of your slideshow later on
i would like to add the proviso however
that we acknowledge
the environmental concerns of several
councillors over development of a
kenworth valley route
that we identify time is short
and i'm sure i don't need to remind you
of the emphasis placed on the benefits
of sustainable travel
in the future high streets fund being
bid being discussed tonight
and the emergency active travel
initiative
however i would like to point out
something we feel
could be further emphasized
ecotourism is something which north
devon and torridge is perfectly
placed to develop surfing
cycling and walking are already at the
heart of leisure activity in this
beautiful area
not to speak of sailing and other water
sports
with forethought and planning a network
of cycle routes
walking routes beaches and accommodation
could all be mapped
together and promoted tourism could be
at the heart of regenerating the area
and make a significant difference to the
local economy
never counsellors has there been a more
opportune moment to regenerate our area
and our community to educate the public
and to make torridge a truly sustainable
environment
for everyone thank you
thank you very much as you say very
opportune that um
this comes up now uh obviously we will
be debating that when the
item comes up on the agenda for uh
councillor haynes's
notice motion so thank you very much
indeed i'm sure we'll be in touch with
you again
thank you
right so um sorry to stop you just to
let you know that council of dart has
now joined the meeting
okay thank you um
so now we go to item five urgent matters
i don't have any urgent matters
steve have you got anything which is not
coming up later or
okay i don't have anything no thank you
so now we go to item 6n which is the
future high street fund which you've got
some
paperwork on as well and an officer is
going to lead on that and that's going
to be
steve okay i was going to give a quick
introduction
uh chris will run through a couple of
slides
and helen shared david hayes to give a
wrongdoing view so
um pleased to introduce such a exciting
project uh for members to consider this
evening i'm not going to go through the
details of the project and steal any of
chris's thunder
because he's put in a lot of hard work
as the the team to
get this project to the stage it's
currently up for any future
to consider so as well as chris
property team legal team financial team
all put in a
a lot of work uh to get this exciting
project
underway it's an excellent example
of how the teams work together with some
of the councillors on the the governance
board
together with members of uh local
businesses local business community and
community groups to bring this stuff to
you
this evening i said it's an exciting
project
not only for biddeford but for the whole
of torridge and we'll have
benefits across the district obviously
has it been such a large project doesn't
come without risk
as most major projects do
but you know the team have worked hard
to work through those risks and mitigate
them
as much as possible and they'll be
explained in a bit more detail
as we go through the presentation um
before handing over to chris i think the
leader councillor james just wanted to
add a few points so after that i'll will
be handed over to chris to run through
the presentation
thank you okay thank you councillor
james
yes thank you chair just to say it is an
exciting project
i congratulate the members that have
worked with the officers
the officers have worked extremely hard
on this some of the members have had a
tremendous input to it
and i just look forward to it coming to
fruition
and just say that this is definitely
torridge going forward
so good luck to everybody on involved in
it
thank you chair thank you very much
any um questions
or statements
i think chris will just run through the
presentation chair if that's okay and
take questions ask them when let's go
all right fair enough
okay uh good evening members um my first
experience of uh
committee via zoom so uh fingers crossed
this goes all right for everyone
um as has been alluded to it's an
incredibly exciting project
uh there's a huge amount of information
that i've included in the report
so i'm going to try and move through
some slides fairly rapidly
i think the key thing to emphasize is
that
huge progress has been made over the
course of nine months
work that would normally have taken up
to about four years to have achieved in
a standard
um project and there's been incredibly
widespread support
across both the district and wider
region and be it from the biosphere
all the local primary schools in
biddeford and secondaries as well
councils and a range of uh charities and
business organizations as well
including kind of chamber and fsb
um as steve was alluding to
his crucial emphasize again that this is
a scheme that will in the long run pay
for itself
um and that will also be key to driving
investment into both biddeford and the
local area um especially in these
difficult times
this is a crucial project for unlocking
job creation
and also for the local authority being
proactive and taking the front foot
in the recovery phase it also doesn't
sit in isolation
it comes a time when
tomorrow i'm going to put in a
significant funding bid for the globe in
torrington
and we've also recently worked with
devon county council
on a very large fundament as part of the
rural mobility fund
for the wholes worthy and wholesome
rural areas
okay so it comes as a background the
fact that
uh biddeford is now one last 101 towns
in this government transformation fund
and we've been encouraged to bid for up
to about five million according to
the value for money data that we can
generate
where we need to demonstrate a two to
one benefit cost ratio and that then
factors in
the actual amounts that we can ask for
it's not just ask for a blanket amount
it has to have gone through
the economists that we've worked through
we've achieved that two to one benefit
cost ratio
we have a very strong strategic fit and
we've worked as hard as we can
on the deliverability given the fact
that unlike many councils this is not
a project that has been taken down from
a shelf i've haven't been previously
worked up
but has been responding to genuine
community need and community engagement
so we've been through a long process
since uh january 2019 when all the towns
were originally involved in discussing
who might move forward but then
looking at building i said a community
governance piece
which has already been alluded to and
then basing all of our work on community
engagement
actually reaching out and making sure
that we're listening to our community
but we also couldn't ignore the fact um
that the week after the draft submission
was put in that the pandemic really hit
hard
so needing to make sure that actually
the proposals that we're putting in
are suitable for the world after the
pandemic
it's sad to say it but actually the work
that we started before the pandemic and
submitted as part of the draft
submission
has very much been vindicated that
actually we feel that we were absolutely
along the right lines
that said the pandemic period did
provide us with an opportunity to
strengthen our deliverability
and to work with a body called igloo
regeneration who
were described by the united nations of
all people or bodies
as the world's first sustainable
property investor
so really strengthening our
deliverability and making sure
that as steve alluded to in terms of
risk that we're
absolutely mitigating as much as we can
there are certain limitations put in
place
for what the fund can be used for so we
undertook a detailed master planning
exercise i think in conversations across
the community
and wider area a lot of people have
flagged up well why aren't we looking to
regenerate for example the key which
might be the the obvious
target and yet when you look at
how the money can be spent on things
like new housing new workspaces public
realm
actually the key is not the right place
for that kind of development
i think that's a longer term
conversation um that might need to take
place
so as part of that governance board we
developed a series of shared
objectives um which actually i think
will be right to come back to
at the end to reflect on whether we all
feel that
we've achieved those but the crucial
thing is that this can't just be about
creating
something glossy and pretty that this
the government word that's being used is
transformation
and we need to make sure that we're not
just almost papering over cracks
or hiding issues that will still be very
much
felt under the surface
as said our process started with deep
community engagement
working with the onion collective
recognized national experts
in going far beyond just scratching the
surface
we've worked with schools we've worked
with charitable organizations business
bodies we've worked with
young and old we asked questions of as
many people as we could find
which led into the development of a
detailed theory of change which was
approved by biddeford town council in
february which will underpin
regeneration in the town for years to
come
and needs to make sure that we're
achieving those goals through the future
high sheet fund as well
so all of that led on to us identifying
the site which has become known as
isaac's yard which comprises
of land which forms part of
herd brothers garage and 51 mill street
which is currently blunt charts
in biddeford as you can see
um at the moment it's still mostly a
functioning
garage although the the term has been
coined by some
that it is a car graveyard and yet
hiding within this space which actually
encompasses a large amount
of the area in between mill street
bridgeton street queen street and cooper
street
there is an absolute sort of potential
um
it's the largest potential developable
space in the heart of biddeford
and nestled within that is also a
stunning heritage
walled garden where as soon as you step
inside the walls of that
uh garden you're protected just both by
the walls
and by the wider buildings around it
meaning that you step
from what's currently a commercial
garage
into a complete oasis of calm where
you're protected from
traffic noises from the town around you
and even from the wind
so here we go this is um the the
architect's impression of how
the space could look a significant
improvement i hope you'll agree on
as i said what is currently a car
graveyard
and we feel that we've very much
achieved a lot of the the principles
that were
picked out by the onion collective work
making sure that we're creating those
community bridges
providing opportunities for interaction
but also through the permeability of it
which isn't just through entrances from
queen street cooper street and mill
street
but will also be achieved by making sure
that there's movement in between
the front and back of existing buildings
which will be able to open up onto the
space
and a number of building owners are
quite keen to be doing that um
in terms of carbon neutrality and uh our
speakers already mentioned the
importance of that
which is we're working with bodies such
as igloo and we've also
engaged actively with the rural
community energy fund
to make sure that we're undertaking
detailed studies
of what will be the right renewables mix
uh
currently thinking along the lines of
ground source heat pumps and
solar panels and all in putting
well-being
and interaction of these spaces front
and center
we're not looking at silos we're looking
at how all the different elements within
this complex
interact support each other and create a
significant multiplier effect
not just having that's just the building
by itself
this project has to continue to evolve
and work better
as the years pass rather than being
stuck in the now
so i whizzed through some of the uses um
many of you were involved when we
were exploring uh use of the town hall
ground floor areas as uh shared
workspace
well the learning from the pandemic is
that actually that shared workspace is
even more crucial
with huge numbers of people having
worked from home and also a lot of
people haven't been
freed up by that process to be able to
work from anywhere
no longer having to be within easy reach
of a certain desk
but we need to use this opportunity as i
said to address underlying issues
and to start talking about how we create
training opportunities how do we create
networking opportunities and really
raise the standard of job creation
within turret and the wider area
again the pandemic has emphasized the
shared importance of
community and the nhs but also of having
efficient structures in place which can
support
everyone not leaving people behind
at the moment councillor clark would
agree with me on this because we had
long discussion about it a couple of
weeks ago
that there remains too much
disjointedness with
charities doing and community bodies
doing fantastic work
but often working in isolation and where
the opportunities for collaboration
joint working and actually building that
wider impact
this project cannot just hide away from
the underlying issues and deprivation
that
impact on our town which all of us know
are there and which will continue to
hold the town and the community back and
the wider area
until we really can certainly address
them which is why we've been working
with a body called collab down in exeter
who are national innovators in this
field
meaning that torridge can learn from
this expertise
and move our provision on again
reducing the duplication and working at
the moment with the nhl
nhs which has to be a real win
cultural again we need this space to be
fun
we want people to come back be it's
locals
who we need to provide for to make their
lives um better and more enjoyable
but also our visitor community and those
of us who live in the area know that
on a wet day such as today we're apart
from now having access to the beach at
westwood ho through a fantastic new
slipway
there's not that wide a variety of
things to do
again in particular for young families
and visitors
having something with technology at its
core but also being able to celebrate
and feel proud of our heritage
and with a vibrant events calendar
stemming out from that to make sure that
we're not just talking about a space
that's open between say ten and four
but really drives footfall throughout
the day
and into the early evening creating a
really positive nighttime economy
which is also vital to make sure that
our younger
members of our community stay locally in
the future
there we go there's a a quick glimpse of
how it might look at the moment
this top quote classy doesn't have to
mean expensive as one
is one that's stuck with me throughout
this process it was actually said
by a year seven girl in a workshop
as part of a democracy week event which
i think was back in last
november that she said she wanted to
feel proud in her town
didn't necessarily want it to be
expensive but wanted to actually
standards to be high and so along with
the
ethos of slow time in the heart of the
town how do we make sure that this is a
vibrant space
where people can enjoy themselves where
you can
spend time and then that can ripple out
to the wider
retail areas around it
and again utilizing a space we've had
conversations with igle regeneration
in terms of our climate emergency about
not wasting or not releasing stored
carbon but maximizing the build that's
there
and the the image there is of a market
up in london actually in elephant castle
called mercato metropolitano which is a
very successful market but which also
offers educational outreach work
to young people who receive free school
meals
and also to their families providing for
them during the summer
or factoring the holidays in general and
offering cookery workshops to ensure a
healthier
lifestyle residential
again not just in there to balance the
books
but to make sure that we're really
creating an aspirational place
where our school leavers where graduates
want to spend time where as part of the
environmental
principle of a 15-minute neighborhood
they really can access
everything they want within those 15
minutes
and really thrive but of course making
sure that we're meeting
our affordable quota because we need to
be leading on that front
and as i said the ward garden which is
an incredibly exciting space
both working with the likes of active
devon to see
leisure events taking place but even
through to having
weddings and wedding receptions hidden
within the heart of the town
and yet feeling completely in an oasis
which is where you'll be delighted to
know that i get to pass on
and i'll pass over to helen bond to talk
about some of the
the financial aspects uh sharing with
david hayes as well
thank you chris that's a very
comprehensive report really interesting
read as well so
well done for you to yourself and all
the team on that one i've got councillor
ford who wants to ask a question at the
station
we'll go ahead and do that can we get
councillor ford
hello hello hello hello
um i've got to be a bit measured here
because i don't want to
break protocol and go on into a part two
item
i do think the officer has done a great
job
but one thing i'd like you to clarify
with
me is with the problem we have got up
cooper street
with a derelict public hate
i did say and i think the council is at
an opportunity
and he is aware of the situation and
we've got to be very careful here which
is why i'm being measured
but we have got the right of a
compulsory purchase on that property and
quite frankly there's serious issues
with it which
could be going ongoing for one two three
who knows four years whatever and it's
right adjacent to this scheme
so i would like him to actually
acknowledge the fact
i can't remember whether it was in or
another officer that council 4 did
suggest this months ago
i'd like him to acknowledge that and
maybe still
could he come back and say whether there
would be a
probability in the near future of maybe
adding to the scheme
because he's absolutely right goes on
about deprivation but this we're gonna
have this lovely scheme which i'm all
for i'm very positive about that that's
lovely it's great
because i think historically it's my
opinion that a bit of a mafia
years ago probably kept biddeford back
into the late 70s early 80s
so i'm all for it but we're going to
have it right next
to what is a falling down public case
which is going to be
more increasing safety and health houses
thank you chair
thank you very much uh chris can you is
it possible to give any sort of
indication on that at all or no
oh with great pleasure and similar way
to counsel forward i'll be careful with
my words
and i think that
in the long run absolutely it would be
fantastic to see
uh that uh public house form part of
this wider project
in a follow-up phase um as we know it is
a very
complicated location at the moment
but in the long run absolutely thank you
very much
okay so we move on to the next part of
the presentation then
oh sorry when mcgolf has
got his hand raised as well in fact
notice chairman um i'm happy just go
first after the presentation for me
please
oh okay fair enough all right
next part okay good evening
um so to outline the financial bid that
we're putting forward to the future high
street fund on behalf of torres district
council
the current financial analysis of this
scheme we're putting forward estimates
the total development value at
9.6 million so from the total cost
analysis the elements eligible for
funding from the future high street fund
are the site acquisition preliminary
costs and a provision of
professional advisors fees this totals
4.28 million under the provision of the
fund this needs to be spent by march
2024
this bid is within the parameters for
smaller towns which the fund suggests is
in the remit of a five million pound
request
the total land acquisition cost of the
scheme are under two million
we've had detailed negotiations with the
two landowners involved throughout this
process
and now have signed heads of terms with
them subject to contract
and future high street fund funding
support
i think we're fortunate in having the
support of these
these two key players in the project the
values agreed in principle reflect the
worth of those assets to the current
owners and the overall value
of them to this project without their
agreement
we wouldn't have this project
unfortunately both parties want to work
with us constructively going forward
if we achieve this level of support from
the fund this leaves additional funding
requirements in the region of 5.4
million based on the current scheme
appraisal
what i would point out is our projected
gross development value
of the scheme by 2029 is in the region
of 8.75 million
this comprises the sales value of the
residential elements and the phased
income
from the commercial parts of this scheme
up to this date
our aim has been to be conservative in
our approach the receipts generated
but the figures have been inputted as a
result of market analysis and expert
input
i think it's useful to establish how
we've arrived at this point of this
presentation to you today
i've been started out with a submission
to mhclg
a rough order of magnitude this was
effectively a basic residual working
valuation based on site areas to
establish the mixed use scheme
this had to be submitted before we'd
actually got any scheme design in place
it's worth pointing out the pace of this
whole project has been quite rapid
and we've been required to bring a lot
of information together and produce a
comprehensive scheme in a very short
space of time
the scheme of this nature would usually
take a number of years to prepare for
we've had to bring this together in nine
months
from the rough order of magnitude and
once we'd appointed hm treasury green
book
book experts we had them on board to
produce a draft submission which
was presented to mhclg in march of this
year
this initial initial project was a much
more intensive scheme
which was illustrated by the likely
costs involved these were going to be in
excess of 12 million leaving a funding
gap of over 9 million
which was likely to escalate this design
process created a beautiful
and ambitious scheme but very simply the
costs and risks involved made it
undeliverable
that lack of deliverability and the
impact of the covert epidemic led us
to a point igley regeneration ever since
then the whole team has worked to
produce a more deliverable project
driving the costs down and bringing the
potential growth development value up
to arrive at the point we're at today
and a final submission for the fund bid
our prime objective with the bid is to
achieve funding to acquire the sites
once we have ownership we can finalize
with scheme design
once we move to the point of having
successfully secured future high street
fund monies our aim is to
start securing additional external
funding on a capital or revenue basis
and we already have interest in this
element from a number of external
parties
but it's important that we choose the
right partners to work with us on this
project
igloo have been instrumental in their
support in this area
they have an sca accredited investment
arm which will allow us to
access both impact and green finance to
ensure that our objectives aren't
compromised
the most cost-effective method of
funding this project would be council
employing its own resources and
potential borrowing from the public
works loan board
and the works we have work we have done
in terms of exploring a detailed
sensitivity analysis with the finance
team
that's david hayes and peter hudson
supports his way of funding the project
and that is why we're here today to ask
full council for their support to this
approach
but we want to stress that this is this
is not our only funding focus
and we aim to access additional funding
to reduce this risk
we also need to focus on the final
designs and bring these together within
the cost parameters we'll be working
with
and this is a challenge and we're well
aware of this the sensitivity of
projects to external cost factors in the
procurement process is well known to all
of us
from projects we've been involved with
previously and currently
the effects of covid 19 could add
further to these pressures but the
implications of this are as yet unknown
the key areas we've assessed through the
sensitivity analyst carried out by the
financial team
we need to concentrate on controlling
build costs and maximizing receipts
that said our fallback position is once
we have ownership of the site
itself there are immediate options for
getting key benefits out of its use and
supporting the town centre
ownership of the sites gives us the
opportunity to create an access into an
open space of the centre of town for
community events
instigating meanwhile uses to ignite
interest and create revenue
we can use the existing resident
residential accommodation on
site to support our temporary
accommodation needs
the garage space provides us with a
covered flexible space providing a food
and drink offer
and a covered events area
and public access to a secure heritage
garden in the grounds of
important historic building
the aim is to spread the risk looking at
a variety of potential uses and uses
and from this we can build a vibrant
environment at the heart of the town
which could link with other projects
like brunswick wharf
if we can secure the grant from the
future high street fund we can move the
scheme forward to achieve its
full potential including the workspace
residential community and cultural
elements
successfully securing the mhclg funding
will mean we can move the whole project
forward into the next
phase and consider the council's future
involvement with the project
and hopefully build a lot of positive
interest around the town
and the district whilst this funding
principally concentrates on the main
centre of torridge if we can
secure funding for this project it can
only act as a positive sign for the
whole district of torridge
thank you thank you very much thank you
councilman golf
thank you very much mr chairman um is
that the report finished now mr chairman
so i understand okay
david hayes who's going to do the the
financial sensitivity
okay get in a minute
all right sorry
hey you'll be pleased to know it's quite
a short brief process from me
this is a great opportunity for the
council
but it would be proven to assess the
risks facing it
sorry i'm getting a little bit of
feedback in the air though i do
apologize
um so the key variables that we modeled
were changes in interest rates
this is the eventual price we'd get for
the sale of the residential units the
future rental income that we would get
from the development
and the build inflation as my colleague
helens re alluded to
build inflation is by far the biggest
key component and variable to this
project and we
modeled various numbers
through the chat it was very hard to
hear you know that we modeled was 10
build inflation for each year of
construction so that's over
three years i have a 20 reduction in
future
rental income from projection and
also 20 less in the receipts of the
residential
units then based on different interest
rates on that worst case scenario on the
current interest rates applicable at the
moment from the
pwlb that would be an annual cost of the
council of 12 000 pounds
and if interest rates rose by two
percent so the pwlb
interest rates went by over two percent
that would be 57
000 pounds however if build costs
were contained and the
um receipts we got from the sale of the
residential user as expected and the
future rental income we got was online
the best case scenario essentially means
that we would generate a positive income
stream to the council and repay back the
council's investment over a period of
between 10
and 12 years none of the modeling we did
assumed any additional grant income
other than what mclg
mclg we're offering so it's not assuming
any additional money from the arts
council
homes england etc there are other
positive impacts of the scheme which are
somewhat difficult to assess like the
impact on business rates the additional
business rates because obviously
depending on the business rates the
businesses are arrive
the valuation office will have to do
that assessment and any additional
income that we'll get from parking will
obviously just be proved in the fullness
of time
so just to recap the members this is a
great opportunity
there are risks to the council but all
the scenarios that we modeled
and hopefully would be improved and the
only ones that really
um led to the project costing the
council money was where the build
inflation was 10
for each year and the sales receipts
were 20
down on the residential units and 20
less rental income was attained than in
the plan
i'll have to take any questions thank
you
thank you david councillor mcgoff now
then
third time's a charm mr cherry there you
go
thank you much um i'd just like to
propose that we approve the four
recommendations
on page 24. um and this opportunity i'd
like to thank the officers within
tourists for it's such a thorough and
detailed report
and all the local partners actually work
so closely to get this regeneration bid
to the stage it is at the moment and
obviously being one of the north ward
members
it's been you know been a proud moment
to be a small part of this regeneration
bid
to put a little bit of input into it in
my opinion this is one of the best
chances bit of desire for at least 50
years to actually regenerate our time
and that working alongside with the
regeneration of brunswick wharf
um i i think things are really starting
to look up now for biddeford and it's
you know it's
it's great that all the tank councillors
and district councils of biddeford i
should support
this bid you know we're working together
um in the right way as we said from the
beginning
and for torridge this is a great project
for us to show the public
we are actually you know we're forward
thinking and dynamic and
we're trying to improve the town it does
need improvement we all know the issues
within the town
if we all bit together this is our
chance here to improve biddeford and i'm
very proud
that this report's come forward thank
you
thank you councilman golf and if you're
proposing that i'm quite happy
more than happy to second that proposal
for the recommendations on page 24.
any any further questions or um you've
got
chair you've got councillor christie's
hand raised and two others
right thank you christy yeah thank you
um yes i'm another north ward councillor
and i'm all in favor of this it really
is a fantastic scheme
and what really excites me about it is
that there has been a scheme for this
area before
put forward tentatively uh it
it doesn't it didn't address the issues
that are being addressed by this scheme
uh this scheme is much song stronger
because it has a real mix of land uses
in this area and they that helps address
all the different issues that are facing
biddeford
um it also i'm very glad to say
preserves the belfast roof
which if you haven't seen it you need to
go and have a look it's actually a very
rare survival
um so i'm glad that's being kept
dr candler's garden which is the
ornamental guard you've heard that
everyone in biddeford calls it dr
candler's garden you used to be able to
visit it once a year
it is exquisite and i'm so glad that
will be part of the scheme as well
and the other thing i did read in the
report is going to be some
archaeological exploration
i look forward to that because this is a
very unusual site actually right in the
middle of a medieval town
which hasn't been disturbed so it could
be quite exciting to see what we
uh see there um i should say that
i did suggest this scheme 12 years ago
so i'm really hoping it goes forward
the other thing is i should mention that
um as chair of the bridge trust the
bridge trusts own
most of bridgeland street and some of
our land does actually border onto
the back of this scheme and i suspect
uh there could well be possibilities of
working together with the bridge trust
on this
so if it goes forward it will meet
chris's
ideas about the charities working
together as well um obviously i can't
speak for the rest of the trust
and some of the counselors are on the
trust uh we're going to have a meeting
fairly soon a real physical meeting
take it from there so congratulations
and if councillor brenton
hadn't seconded it i would thank you
thank you
thank you very much so cam show edge is
next
thank you chair yes i i too i would have
seconded it as well because i'm one of
the 10 coasters as well in the in in
biddeford
i think it's a wonderful opportunity for
us um
i just think that uh all councillors on
torrance should be
supported on this that would um
send in a message to anybody that wants
to come in and
developers and and
anybody that wants to to come in with
some funding for this
they would see that torridge is serious
in doing this for for biddeford
it's wonderful to see it's a derelict
site that's wanted to be developed for
over 30 40 years and i think
about time it's been done and i hope
that
all councilors will be supporting us
tonight thank you
thank you very much no councillor lock
is next
yeah i would also have queued up the
second the um recommendation but i think
it's a wonderful opportunity and
congratulations again to all the
officers concerned
um i'd also think it's wonderful that
all the
town councils have worked together with
all their outside partners so closely
and they're all singing from the same
hidden sheets i think that's really
interesting
um if our bid has got to be submitted by
the 31st of july
we at times scale when you were here if
we've been successful in habit or not
uh in standard government speak i think
it's autumn 2020 which
could unfortunately cover a fairly wide
window
just one other point off the cuff i was
very interested in chris's presentation
slide
a picture of the elephant and castle
that certainly changed since i lived
there in 1968
thank you cancer watson no no
okay
yeah i i also would like to support this
uh
this earth um project i think it's
fantastic um being out in the sticks
certain heartland
um i know that you know tourism is a a
big part of our income and um you know i
work once a week at the milky way and i
know that you know
it needs uh needs uh something like this
to
make it really good so yeah i i would
say that
all of my um um people i represent
it would wholeheartedly agree that this
needs to be done
thank you very much well it would be a
benefit to the whole
area of the torah just for sure so um
council gov
no no no got your name
no other hands are raised chair okay
thank you for that
so um we've got a uh
proposition namely that the
recommendations on page 24.
councillor leather's just raised his
hand and so is
thanks chair hey i'll be brief i i think
it's a fantastic
scheme this and speaking as an ex-mayor
of biddeford an ex biddeford town
councillor
it's wonderful and picking up on what
counselor chris has said
what an opportunity to to have an
archaeological dig on the site there and
find out
i'm sure that it'll uncover a lot of uh
interesting artifacts from this
but i do pick up on what councillor ford
said as well that
the patching parrot in cooper street
needs
to be involved somehow i think in this
scheme and i hope that can come about
but
it is a good scheme and in the short
time scale
it's been put together with all the
partners who are agreeing to it i think
it's
brilliant so i'm wholeheartedly in favor
chair
thank you very much councillor bushby
my two other two uh northward
councillors have
quite widely said you know this is a
fantastic scheme for the town
um and it's been it's actually been a
privilege to be
a part of the governance board uh board
right from the
right from the inception of this uh of
this project
uh and it's been it's been really
interesting to to work with the officers
um lead ably led by chris fuller and you
know
see there see their expertise you know
at first hand because uh
you know it's it is a you know very
encouraging when we've got officers of
this caliber driving
this kind of uh project through um
you know everything that's been said
about this development in the town
center
is is absolutely uh correct and i i
support that
um i've lived in benefit all my life
i've seen lots and lots of
um demolition in the town from the
strand cinema to various other
high-profile parts of the town and it's
delightful to actually
um be part of uh
something which is going to see
something as uh as large as this
potentially rise in the center of the
town i think it'll be absolutely
fantastic
in addition to that i think we've also
got
um you know the planning game uh
in in planning speak um is actually the
removal of a commercial premises within
the town centre
you know that hasn't been mentioned you
know thus far but um
you know garages in the in the of this
size and
in the town center now you know aren't
really appropriate and this will really
really
add to you know the whole development of
the town center so
along with everyone else i
wholeheartedly support it thank you
thank you very much so tom will you know
more speakers
that's correct yeah thank you very much
in that case i'll go to the vote then
obviously it's recorded that's all votes
are so
as i say the recommendations are on page
24. so
sandra if you'd like to start off please
yes chair
councillor bowton i'm four
councillor brenton four councillor
bright
four councillor brown
councillor brown or
thank you councillor bushby or
cancer craigie or
chancellor christie or answer clark
or pencil or culture hanken
or counselor dot
poor counselor ford
need your mute counselor forward please
four
thank you counselor
pencil hackett oh pencil harding
four pencilla haynes or
pencilla hawkins or
pencil hairpool poor
pencil hicks
need to touch the screen and i'm mute
please
thank you councillor hudson oh
jones or counselor laws
or pencilla langfood or
penciller leather or
penciller lock or pencil mcgough
good luck biddeford four councillor
mackenzie
four penciller manly
or councillor newton
or cancer pennington or
chancellor rossi four wholeheartedly
councillor watson
dancer watson
for a cigarette
thank you that's unanimous chair
thank you very much councillors it's
very important that we've actually
agreed
unanimously to support this because i'm
sure that
will make a difference when the bid goes
into to government
the very fact that we've got a very
diverse council and yet we've all
supported it
so thank you indeed thank you so now we
go on to item
seven notice emotion and the first one
is from
councillor mcgoff and i'll ask him to
present his case for
this notice of motion to go obviously to
cnr and then i'll ask for a seconder
but there'll be no debate about it
tonight because it will if it's
successful we'll go to cnr
thank you councilman mcguff thank you mr
chairman would you like me to read the
emotion out mr chairman
uh well we've all had it in front of us
um councillor hutchings has got his uh
hand up is that right uh
tom sorry sorry
yes that's right yeah okay it's
councilor hutchings you've got a
point now i was just just raising my
hand to um second emotion
oh i see a bigger party okay all right
fair enough when we get to that point
so uh cousin mcgoff you you've presented
were
your notice motion there is presented to
council
yes mr chairman yet
sorry do you want to add to it in terms
of
um getting them to agree to it is
it's the motion that sort of public can
see it right okay
because we're live on youtube is
emotional to see it
you know yes it is well as you can see
then
um another another bite in the cherry
and hopefully this time
it's more detailed for the councillors
to hopefully support this time to go to
cnr
and this time i'll actually get some
implementation for the uh for the
business owners within the town centers
um time is key for me so thank you okay
thank you for that so it's been and uh
councillor hutchins
i understand you're you're going to
second it so yes please
that's it right so this opposed the
second hit so we'll go to the vote then
thank you chair councillor bowton
four penciller brenton or
councillor bright four councillor brown
moore councillor bushby or
chancellor craigie or chancellor
christie
or councillor clarke
or pennsylvanian
or counselor dart
for chancellor ford
against councillor gab
for councillor hackett
four councillor harding
four chancellor haynes or
councillor hawkins or
cancer heppo against
councillor hick four
pencil hudson
councillor hurley against
councillor hutchins
councillor inch
for councillor james
james
councillor james you're muted yeah i'm
sorry four
thank you cancer james councillor jones
or cancer laws
come on wake up
counselor laws oh
thank you councillor langford four
councillor leather four penciller lock
henson mcgough or
councillor mckenzie against
councillor manly or
counselor newton or
cancer pennington abstain on the grounds
that i'm chair of external ons
and may have a right of calling on the
cnr decision so i want to keep my hand
open so abstain thank you cancer
pennington
councillor rossi paul
sorry i'm four
thank you councillor watson against
thank you we have
five against one abstention 29 in favor
thank you very much counselors that will
obviously this notice of motion will go
to cnr for
further deliver deliberations so
we now go on to notice the motion b
from councillor haynes so would you like
to introduce your
notification counselor haynes thank you
chair
um as you all know um there was a big
increase in cycling under lockdown
as people stayed at home and
car use dropped considerably pollution
levels
dropped amazingly and we experience
quiet roads in the sight of people
quietly cycling along
um we have an ideal opportunity
now coming out of lockdown to promote
and continue
this trend towards cycling it is vital
if we're going to
maintain reductions in pollution
um it's also very important as the
government has recently said
and as kathy slaughter pointed out that
uh obesity is a huge
concern a third of two thirds of the
population in the uk
is obese and cycling um could
considerably contribute to um
reduction of obesity um
cycling um i
basically i'm asking that this council
um engages with other organizations
are primarily the county council of
course but with
parishes and with one northern
devon which is promoting cycling through
one of its special groups and also
to relate to a vibrant new organization
that kathy slaughter represents a cycle
action group
mainly the role i see of torridge is to
identify
cycling and also walking routes of
course
um or not on our public roads
if possible where there is an
opportunity to put in cycle tracks
um and also to promote separate routes
um isolated from public roads
such as the kenworth valley route which
has been on the
cards in the local plan for several
years
and we've discussed this quite a lot
recently at council we really need to
get on with that
working with the county um
debuted holdsworthy link if that's still
feasible
um sorry cycle track walking track and
riding horse riding as well has been
suggested
um it's vital i think to have links with
the tarka trail because this can
increase
uh commuting uh possibilities to
barnstable etc
and also increase our tourism offer
as kathy slaughter pointed out um
kathy's group the cycle action group has
come up with several
suggestions which i think we need to
suck
they need to circulate to councillors
really um
one one route they're talking about is
down through manteo way to join up with
the targa trail and the bridge
um i see a great possibility if the
funding was there to create a track
going down there um i see a big
possibility that torridge
can um require developers under planning
to uh contribute section 106s towards
proper cycle
links for example the torrington
creamery
application three applications which are
currently being considered
and also looking at twenty mile hour
safe routes
and uh generally a reduction
indirect methods reduction of car use
car sharing uh possibly river taxes i
think
that's been talked about at some point
um
electric car points of course um
the county is trying to get a scheme
going county wide for that
electric bikes i think chris fuller is
looking at that
um little things like bike racks in
opportune places et cetera et cetera
but the big question is just to turn
wind up in a minute sorry um who's how
are we going to push this forward i
understand that
sean harrington is the officer who
represented his council recently at one
north devon when they inaugurated
cycle group we need a clear line of
responsibility
to for this to promote cycling
it should also it would hope coming out
in the carbon
reduction plan which is due at the end
of this month a whole
raft of ideas for the cycling
it needs to be taken forward and i would
like sort of confirmation that that's
going to be the case through
a designated officer or through a
working group or whatever
and also and very immediately to wind up
sorry
um the government second tranche of
government money for cycle and walking
routes is um applications are due ins by
the 7th of august
so i very much hope that this council
has forwarded
um suggestions for roots to one north
devon who i gather
representing us and north devon district
council in getting
pushing forward our proposals and
particularly the kenworth valley route i
think
where we hopefully can get some
government money thank you very much
thank you very much councillor haynes um
i need a secondary
this pleased with somebody second now i
would well i'll happily second it
somebody else yeah all right
did you say you would second it i'll
second epic and just say that
we are looking at this um the cycleway
stuff but i would suggest it goes to the
climate change working group um as
an emergency issue to look at um because
there is funding available
but we have already started to look at
it as a council of the way forward
and uh and uh if we go back a little bit
generally wallace did write to devon
county a year or so ago
asking who was replacing the officer who
retired and we still haven't had an
answer yet so we will pursue that
okay okay thank you for that we do
obviously do need to push this
if the council approved this notice of
motion uh and it
obviously makes sense to join up with
north devon if if
they're willing but uh we mustn't lose
the opportunity that's for sure there's
a lot of people
are wishing to speak and we can debate
this because it doesn't have any
financial implications
uh it's a no submission in principle so
uh the next one is on my list is
cancer mcgoff is that right
yeah thank you much mr chairman i'm i'm
just in full support of this
giving the um conservative government
initiative and the funding and providing
for it
so if you wanna be both mps which are
fully on board with us
i'm pretty sure we get some money for
north devon and torrid so i'm filled
with support thank you chairman
thanks very much thank you councillor
ford next
hello chair yeah i can hear you yeah
yeah
i actually i did pop my hand up first
actually just to clarify that because i
was going to second it
um so i'll keep it brief um who can't
second it and um
coach reigns is very passionate about it
he's absolutely right because it's a
long time ago when i was up counting we
were
talking about a trap at the kenworth
valley and quite frankly
we can talk to the coast come on where
they don't but it's about time something
happens i'm in total support of that
thank you counselor christy yeah thank
you i was going to second it as well
actually
um yeah i hope it goes there because
it's been in my election leaflet for the
last four
years um yeah we finally got into the
local plan
and i should explain that um ten years
ago i got the bridge trust to offer 40
000 pounds to devon county to get this
uh built
it didn't go ahead then for all sorts of
reasons so i hope it does go ahead now
uh if any of you have been on the target
trail during lockdown
it's been astonishing the number of
cyclists out there
uh really quite incredible i hope it
goes ahead because
finally we will get a level safe route
to the sea
from biddeford and people go through the
kenworth valley they will go through
biddeford it's got a huge
um tourist possibilities here and one
other thing i should add
there might be some publicity because um
this wednesday i'm actually taking uh
some tv producers to show them what
remains of the westwood whole line
for that program i think it's called
lost railways of britain or something
but they're actually coming down here so
i think we could really
make something of this now thank you
thank you for that thank you cancer
craigie
thank you um i just i also wanted to
second it
um i fully support it and i would like
to see the introduction of
cycle charging points on the key if we
could um
possibly bring that forward as part of
the motion or
as part of the debate on the recycle you
know the
decarbonisation committee and perhaps
the district council could fund some
cycle charging points next to the
existing
cycle racks all right thank you
thank you very much thank you um
councillor james you've already spoken
so um any other
further you've got two councillor inch
and councillor bushby
first of all thank you chair yes as the
democratic councillor
of um the only one torridge i will left
to say that um
the kenworth valley um cycle route is on
the
is on the burner on the front burner and
we are looking into
uh trying to get um the landowners there
to
uh give up some land so that we can
have a cycle route from biddeford uh to
westford hill and i agree with coach sir
christie
this this has been an ongoing threat
thing
and i have informed them county council
of the
kind offer of the british trust of their
money and i have asked them to contact
bridge trust
right
thank you you froze there for a minute
but it must be the weather
uh right so no councillor bushby then
thank you chair
um yes i'll be also an agreement with
this but i have a question
if i may um council aims mentioned uh
cathy slaughter who was the public
speaker uh right at the start
she um put a map up on the uh on the
screen i don't know that we can see this
map again but
the the map had a variety of little
colored crosses which denoted uh various
routes
that uh such a a scheme could
could actually follow and right down in
the bottom right hand corner
there's a little yellow box says
cycled scuderia which is um on better
key
yeah that's on the pill actually yeah
i don't know whether it's a point of
order i should raise but should we be
it is that private um cycle shop
anything to do with this group that uh
you know this uh psycho group that kathy
slaughter
referred to if it is i don't think we
should be promoting one business
um on a cycle route of this type
i understand what you should i
i understand we'll clarify that one it's
just it doesn't look at those
dots but well it's it's the it's the
only cycle
shop that's highlighted on the entire
route
and all the routes seem to have to
either start
or terminate more or less well
fairly close to cycle screwed area all
right
we'll inquire about that one thank you
yes an officer's got an answer now
yeah officer answer yeah
um best of my knowledge this is a
community action group it's not just in
biddeford it's in torridger it's in uh
north devon as well in barnstable um
it's a
community cycling group it's i don't
think it's not sponsored or anything
okay so is it just coincidence that's
there
it seems to me a rather odd coincidence
you've got
cycle scooteria highlighted there well
maybe they just
pointed out because that's a cycle shot
which can serve as
cyclists i don't think there's any other
site is there another one in biddeford i
don't know
no no there isn't thank you no
all right thank you for that so now
we've got
um councillor bright
thank you chair uh i also like to
support this motion
because i've been working with andrew
seywell uh
who's our democratic councillor in our
area about doing a cycle route
along to the greenway site from ataka um
from the tiger trail but i'd also like
to see a
further trail developed going from the
trail to the town center i know a lot of
different routes have been
discussed over history but
i do think that if we're going to have a
motion like this now's the time to try
and push for
it some more yes
we can all go on the table for
discussion that's for sure
because um torrington does have a large
um cycle
tourism kind of a movement
over the summer of seeing quite a lot
more tourists
cycling around rather than just you know
normal driving tourists i suppose
yes yeah station hill is a challenge
there isn't it
very much so right thank you for that so
i think now we'll um
move to sorry country we've got some
more coming in now
uh councillor pennington thank you
chair um just to stay a few years ago
used to be a bus at 386 bus i think we
used to carry the uh
cycles all the way to old campton and it
was a downhill cycle all the way back to
biddeford keene early
i just yeah joking it never was
go on all i'm saying is that um there's
a lot of torrents beyond bitty food and
um i think there could be other means of
encouraging tourism in the area
i hope that's involved in this
discussion thank you chair
i can tell you for painful experiences
not downhill from
oakhampton to biddeford and never mind
some of it is my counselor
laws i think is next
thank you chair um chair
i have no confidence at all in the
county in this project
uh in 1990 when i was first on torridge
it was a high priority with the county
became with root and it didn't progress
um and i don't think we should be
looking at a partnership
i think this council should pick up the
mantle
and uh look at it as a standalone
project why do we actually
need these other people i just fee
again it gets muddled and the
reason it failed in 1990 is nobody
had the bottle to actually face major
lomas
um we need to be talking to people and i
think this council
could have that route done and dusted in
five years
um
but the point is council of the laws is
more than just the kenmoth valley it's
it's a much wider picture than that so i
do think we should be working in
partnership with north dakota if we're
going to be
successful in any of this so however
that's
my my view cancer harding is next
counselor harding yeah thank you chair
um yeah i'm in full support of this um i
know the landowners uh fairly well being
a farming background um i know that
major loomis would have
definitely um had a bit to say about it
in these times i used to do a lot of
work for him um but basically
i think he would have put past if you if
you can stand your ground with him
now david is a different matter and i
think you know
with these helicopters and that there is
some movement and i think you know we
just got to talk to the man
um on the other on the other side of
this
you know you're talking about um the
cycle way and that there's another thing
i would like to get going for
for biddeford there used to be a walk
from biddeford all the way down to
dartmouth called the mariners way
and this is something that would be
easily put
put together and just makes biddeford a
a a a nice hub
um you know it's 77 miles and uh it
you know it just helps a little bit of
tourism and and the footpath's already
there you just need to stop the
the signs changed and um highlight it
anyway i i just thought i'd just support
it and just uh say that
thanks thank you it'll all be considered
that's for sure
um tom who's next on there tom
that's everyone so thank you very much
look we'll move to the vote now
um it's been proposed and seconded
so sandra would you do the voting please
yes chair councillor bowton
or councillor brenton
for councillor bright
or councillor brown or
ansel bushby or cancer craigie
or councillor christie
or cancel counselor gab
ball chancellor hackett poor
chancellor harding four chancellor
haynes
[Music]
sorry thank you
councillor hawkins or
cancer heckle for pencilla hicks
or cancer hudson oh
chancellor harry penciller hutchins
or penciller inch
for counselor james
or cancer jones
or counselor laws or
penciller langford for
chancellor leather or penciller lock
or hansel mcgoff
i got a point of clarity i don't think
it's acceptable to talk about members of
the public
it should be part two when you mention
the lomas family
but it's what uh i'm supporting i'm
gonna support the motion
to you but i don't believe you've uh
acted correctly if i mentioned members
of the public
it should be in part two we're talking
about that i like this uranus i think
it's bang out of order
are you four against
i said i was four chairman but i'm not
i'm not for that mentioned members of
public that's wrong totally wrong
you councillor mcgruff councillor
mckenzie
four councillor manly
paul councillor newton
paul chancellor pennington or
councillor rossi four penceler watson
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much thank you councillors
this is again boring you know all this
agreement it's just too much to cope
with
um nevermind we go now to um
move to part two as i explained at the
beginning you know i think we need to
re-examine this
process but nonetheless we have to vote
on whether
we move into part two our opposing
movement part two yeah
let's look at it somebody
yes yeah thank you
oh vote again no no
[Music]
right thank you chair councillor belton
oh councillor brenton
or chancellor bright
or chancellor brown
chancellor bushby or hitler
four let's afford four
that's the grab four councillor hackett
four councillor hiding four
councillor haynes or
councillor hawkins or
chancellor heppell ball chancellor hicks
four pencil hudson
james or cancer jones
or cancer laws
or counsellor langford
four penciller leather or
counselor lock or pencil mcgoff
or anthony mckenzie
cancer manly or counselor newton
or spencer pennington or
unanimous chair thank you very much
councillors
and at this point we say goodbye to
members of public who've been following
on youtube thank you very much for
taking an interest and as i said because
this is part two
we now have to uh uh well
cut you off basically so thank you very
much